>>Marco: Guys, let me have one more
picture, 'cause I just realized,
when you guys win the Grammy,
you guys need a good picture
to have up on the top.
>>Narrator: These nine students from
diverse backgrounds came together
for the first time to participate
in a creative experiment
at the NAMM music convention
in Anaheim.
>>Marco: We have students
from four different schools.
We have a combination of an opera
singer to hip hop producers.
We have coupla brass players.
We have a guitar player.
We have a couple of rappers.
So we'll see in this big
stew what actually comes up.
>>Narrator: They would have
just six hours to create
and record an original tune and
produce a music video about it,
aboard a high tech
rolling recording studio,
the John Lennon educational tour bus.
>>Steve: And whenever we actually
finish recording the song,
we normally come up here.
They all sit here, have
the engineer sitting here,
and we will create the music video,
using these computers
here in the front studio.
>>Narrator: The bus has been on the
road since 1998, stopping at schools
and events around the
country, offering small groups
of students a glimpse of the
world of professional recording
and video making, and an
opportunity to collaborate
with top flight recording
artists and skilled engineers.
>>Herminio: Imagine
peace, Paz, Imagine peace.
>>Narrator: All for free.
>>Boy: That's what we needed.
>>Brian: Our whole reason for
being is to supplement, support,
and inspire music and video
programs, and teachers
and communities and leaders.
>>Boy: You guys, can everybody hear
themselves while they're playing?
>>Brian: The more opportunities
we can expose young people to,
the more chances they have to
imagine themselves as successful,
professional, happy, creative people.
>>Rob: I mean, whatever sound
you want, we can give you.
>>Narrator: Engineers Rob Healey,
Herminio Quiros and Steve Miller live
on the bus for ten
months out of the year.
At each stop, they serve as
mentors, showing students how
to run the high tech gear.
>>Rob: You're going for a
string sound there, man?
>>Narrator: And helping to
jumpstart the creative process.
>>Rob: If we get, you know, a little
tiny riffle, decide if that's chorus
or not, and then we can
even move on from there.
>>So have you guys been working
on any riffs or anything lately?
>>Boy: We had this one.
I don't know about this one,
but it's like [plays guitar].
>>Irving: At first it
was just hard, you know,
trying to get the different genres
and stuff, trying to collaborate,
and then everyone had
different ideas,
from their background
or whatever they played.
So we just-- we just--
>>Ryan: Everybody brought
something to the table.
>>Irving: Yeah, to the tables.
>>Marco: To me, the
fundamental component
of creativity is one's
ability problem solve.
And I think that in any creative
project that you go into,
whether it's movie, whether it's
music, whether it's photography,
design, math, science, social
studies, language arts,
I think at the basic core is
your ability to problem solve,
and I think that this gives kids
the confidence to take risks.
>>Boy: I like writing
about what's true.
I don't like writing
about what's fake.
>>Ryan: The tools that
you learn through music,
like you can apply to
any aspect in life.
I mean, 'cause you have
to have discipline,
like 'cause sometimes
you know, like dang,
I can't go out party this weekend.
I gotta record, I gotta
practice, you know what I mean?
So you get discipline.
>>Boy: Oh, do you wanna
do like the last measure--
>>Mike: One of the great
untold lessons of music is
that when a kid learns music,
the kid learns how to learn,
and that's a lesson then can be
applied to the study of mathematics
or language or history or
anything else, because learning how
to learn is the secret
to successful education.
>>Rob: You guys ready to do this?
All right, Five, six, seven, eight.
>>Fernando: Building their character,
showing people how to analyze,
how to proscribe solutions
to difficult problems.
I think they're lifelong
lessons that carry
on to everything that you do in life.
>>Rob: All right, guys,
let's start it again here.
>>Fernando: So even
though I'm teaching music,
I'm trying to teach more than that.
You know, I think it's more
important than the notes on the page
or the performances
that come out of kids.
If you just hear the
kid playing a song,
then you miss the whole picture.
>>Narrator: With the rhythm
and solo tracks laid down,
it's time to record the vocals.
>>Boy: -- that you will live to tell.
I've been through a lot
growing up through these years,
but the knowledge that I
gained, I said, we're my peers,
teenagers and we won't stop.
>>Narrator: At most bus stops,
renowned recording artists
like Al Jarreau swing by to
add their talent to the mix.
Today's guest artist is Casey Brown.
>>Casey: Nice voice.
So are you wanting to do that, and
you want me to harmonize with you,
or do you want me to do that?
>>Boy: Whatever, whatever works.
>>Casey: I think you should do that,
and then I'll harmonize with you.
>>Boy: Let's do that,
that'd be sweet.
>>Narrator: After the
audio tracks are recorded,
the musicians switch hats and
become video producers and actors,
lip syncing a stage performance
and scouring the surrounding area
for additional footage to
integrate into the final piece.
>>Rob: The second half of the day
is always spent shooting video
and editing the video.
So Miguel is editing.
He had a bunch of stuff
already laid out
and had been using
the rough audio mix,
while Herm is completing the
final mix in the back studio.
>>Miguel: I'm syncing the
footage with the song,
so I'm trying to put it all together
so that-- so it goes flawless,
so you won't be able to notice what's
going, or if it's right or wrong,
which is why I just wanna
capture like the whole thing.
Oh, that was nice.
>>Marco: Giving the
students an opportunity
to learn both the audio part of
storytelling or the audio part
of communicating, as
well as the visual part
of communicating is
extremely important.
So if the kid wants to tell
a sad story, then they know
that they can pull an A minor
chord and visually, there's colors
that you would choose and
color palette to communication.
>>Miguel: We're trying
to like final style.
We were going for more like the
kinda gritty black and white.
>>Marco: Regardless of whatever
field these kids choose to go to,
these are skills that they'll be
able to bring to their jobs and say,
"Hey, this is what I can do."
I can communicate in English,
Spanish and multimedia.
>>Herminio: Cool, right?
>>Boy: That's awesome.
>>Boy: Sounded good.
>>Narrator: The bus only accommodates
a small group of students
at each stop, but it's an
exemplary learning experience
that can be replicated at any school,
with a relatively small
investment in hardware.
And while these students
may not strike it rich
in the recording industry,
their experience this day
and their connection
to music is priceless.
>>Marco: Mr. Fingers, here we
go, Mr. Bernal, right here.
>>Mike: There are a lot of kids
for whom music is their
ticket to stay in school.
It's what'll motivate 'em.
It'll what'll keep them interested.
And when public policy officials,
whether they're governors
or legislators start thinking
about cutting arts programs
and music programs, they
need to think again.
>>Marco: Here it is, ladies
and gentlemen, the video.
See "Paz."
[ music video ]
>>Singer: Where the new is
coming out, ready to explode,
and I won't stop, until it's
shown a collaboration worldwide.
>>Man: Most of my students do not go
on to become movie
producers or musicians.
They go on to their
other professions,
but I know that having had this
experience, the kids learn how
to work with others, how to convince
others of the concept that they have,
how to listen and bring in ideas.
And I think those are
very valuable lessons.
[ song plays ]
>>Adrian: Me personally, I feel that
this bus itself gives a lot of hope
for dreams that a lot of youth have
themselves in music and photography
and film productions, because
it shows that, you know,
there's a chance out there, and it's
about just going for
what you love to do.
>>For more information on What Works
in Public Education,
go to edutopia.org.